mother's day weekend is this weekend so
we're so excited to be teaming up with
jurgen skincare for a very special
segment it is special to me um in honor
of their a mom is a mom campaign
celebrating all moms no matter their
path to motherhood we're chatting mom to
mom with someone who helps make our show
look fabulous please welcome someone
who's very dear to me
it's our graphics designer and new mom
megan mochi
congratulations thank you um we call her
the mooch too like she's you're so epic
and important to the show and i love you
so much i love you too i'm so happy to
see you again
we have missed you
so much you're back thank goodness
um and um you have a four-month-old
daughter named sayla
and oh my god that's the most beautiful
picture well jurgen celebrates new moms
um and moms who have been through it all
and they've been um making people a
little more comfortable for years and in
honor of that um megan is actually to be
the interviewer and ask a few questions
to me which is so weird and fun
i'm always the one asking questions and
i'm also just excited to see what you've
come up with yes um
all right are you ready it's my first
the first one is do you ever have an
overwhelming need to not miss a single
moment in your kid's life for instance
my daughter's first laugh happened in a
different room and i was so bummed that
i wasn't in the same room with her oh my
god that is painful i heard it but it
wasn't like in person okay at least
you've heard it yeah you have the audio
memory yes yeah i am i actually switched
careers because of it i didn't want to
be on movie sets and like miss that
first step and i did i got olives on
video i was like
um like the holy grail yeah i don't you
know i just i think the things i funny
enough fear
are just making sure my kids can come
and talk to me about everything that is
like the hook for me the brass ring of
like how can i create these
relationships with my kids that they can
turn to me and talk to me
about anything and everything okay let's
move on to the second one how do you set
aside time for yourself do you wake up
earlier or do you make a schedule so
that you can find time
sometimes i'll stay up late to watch tv
um every once in a while i'll catch a
sunday that's a miracle and i'll grab
that remote control and i'll think of
all the things i could do with my life
and i just sit there and binge watch
television
that sounds about typical okay okay i
just didn't know if you had a secret no
i um i am trying to figure out what
balance is and i'm still working on it
that's good advice okay last one okay
i'm learning how to make sure everyone
gets their fair share of time with sayla
okay how do you balance making sure
everyone in your friends and family
group get enough time with your kids
i mean i think it's just honestly making
plans like send out a group text maybe
have a few people over at the same time
make a little bit of a
festive moment out of it so you're not
having to make 20 different one-on-ones
maybe group effort have some snacks have
some drinks have you and your friends
and hanging out with salah like kind of
like an open house make it really
celebratory and
it's it's just more the more the merrier
and and better time economics as well
love that i'll say this um as a mom you
you
wear your heart on your sleeve and i'll
do everything i can to be the best
person i can for my kids they have
inspired me
as sayla
will inspire you
because when it's just you you can kind
of stay a kid and then you have a kid
and it's
your turn to grow up in a weird way but
i will say growing up isn't overrated i
really like it i really love being an
adult i really like being an adult too
well moochie i'm so glad you're back i
love you we don't do the show without
you we never will you're so invaluable
um and just in time for mother's day
jurgen skin care is releasing a new
limited edition perfume that smells just
like that iconic cherry almond scent of
their original scent
moisturizer and megan and our entire
studio audience are going to go home
with one today alongside of a 50 gift
card to walgreens
and to find out how you can get a chance
to win a limited edition jergens
original scent perfume check out all the
official jergens instagram jergens us
[Music]